hello guys i'm ryan right i'm gerry so
today we're gonna check out a video from
a channel called I want my Lauren it's
from Lauren Francesca she has
guest-starred on the real rejects she
has given me the authority the
permission to use this video in its
entirety to do a reaction to it oh man
and guess who's in it guess is in Lauren
Francesca yes has Lamar Francesca guess
who else is in it um shut up Jerry it's
me I'm in it i'm one of the stars of
this video oh no we're really yeah
there's a special cameo by tyra Magnus
but who the [ __ ] really cares right yeah
it's all down me hakkasan is not in it
um he is in japan so i don't know i mean
could have like you know skyped in a
performance on a computer something been
like this specialist you have to call
never mind let's do source yeah thanks
Jerry this is the moment you've been
waiting for finally met the perfect guy
he's smart in touch with his feminine
side
teaching you now but there's a time
where you're going to have to do this
yourself lady I really did really real
life here are some tips for dating
someone who stores all them over turn
your partner on their side facing away
from you turn on a fan doesn't work if
you have a fan handy put it next to the
bed and turn it on many people find ways
of a fan is effective and drowning out
the sound of snoring okay maybe you can
seek therapy I'm sorry there's no cure
for snoring you can sleep when I'm out
working you have to make the necessary
adjustments to your life accept who he
is optibotimus gently prop up your
pattern of pillows behind their neck and
head and back murder just suffocate them
wait love them hit his face love his
face love his snores love him for his
soon items know what I should get a new
mattress go to Brooklyn bedding dr.
Lydia force get shipped free opened up
let those durable Lake tech comfort
layer powerful for and soft quilted
pillow top and press try it out wow that
is comfortable like too comfortable to
share hashtag best mattress ever sleep
in separate rooms the cap should be
comfortable enough for him I'm the ideal
yeah thanks so much for watching this
video and thank you to road and Ryan and
nepotism TV for directing this video it
was so awesome and very special thanks
to Brooklyn bedding for giving me this
awesome mattress given that teddy bear
country ahead in the world totally use
my code Lauren perfect you know it off
make sure you subscribe to all these
guys they're going to make sure you give
this video a like leave a comment below
which was your favorite favorite part of
the video and to
team thank you again Brooklyn Betty com
I love you guys and peace well done
Lauren I was edited well i gotta say
there was a lot of improv that was not
used I'm sure you're interested Jerry
arey interviewing me and now that I am
the star of a sketch what's going
through your mind as you watch yourself
um damn am I good okay you know like wow
I look at myself and I'm like this is
amazing clearly I'm not the most
in-shape yet i'm like i could totally
see why a woman would be so drawn to me
because of my confidence now we all know
that reacting is reacting but some also
say that acting is reacting how do you
feel about that would be that is agree
that is totally true because a lot of
people prepare what they're about to do
and prepare what they're about to say
they prepare a reaction I mean just just
in the reaction world and you can see
that people do that you know like they
they prep the reactions or forced so in
the world of acting reacting is the way
you should really let your performance
go how it's working with your partner
I'm teaching an acting seminar in a
couple months so keep a look out for
what's your favourite swearword um come
[ __ ] kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] just works in
any given situation everyone knows what
you're talking about no what's next for
ryan right well i'm planning on doing
some masturbation pornography I have a
girlfriend so I cannot you know do
actual porn with like another person so
it's gonna be masturbation um while I'm
snoring and to prepare for the role I
reverential you're gonna do like the
porn the lively a version of this video
cuz snoring is it's hard you're gonna
ride hard excessive snoring guy into
your torture because a lot of people
can't do you know like you know I snore
when I sleep this is appropriate time
for that I snore when I sleep now here's
the thing yeah I I don't care what I'm
like when I'm snoring yeah
so I had to learn to be aware while I
was sleeping on how to snort some were
like you know what you should just
record yourself at night and then play
back the audio I said nay I'm gonna
learn to be awake while I'm asleep what
that's the Brian right method abuse your
body and never read a little fun
background on the short film that on a
sketch whatever you want to call it
Tyrone Magnus he was just hanging out
with me accompany me that day and they
were like wow there's gotta be a way we
could use him and he didn't have a shirt
that would resemble a therapist luckily
I had a shirt that would resemble it
there that would be the closest thing
sir now I know it's not ideal but hey
it's better than what he had on so
you're good toxically as a costume
designer yeah some ways I do everything
for everyone okay and people are gonna
make jokes but the fact that isn't the
same bed as Lauren if you want to know
the truth no nothing happened at all I
really didn't want to but damn was she
persistent that's actually three
separate shots of all you on the bed
single like yellow and then they merge
the three so it looks I'm dedicated I
slept through all that slept do all that
and then when cut was yelled I'd wake
the [ __ ] up I had no idea we were
filming listen guys enough comedy for
today yeah enough for the nut house in
comedy stylings theory fix if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe today
become a reject reasons to jerry is a
playlist I features all videos that
feature Jerry's face and dank ass Stubbs
is a podcast on this channel hosted by
Jerry where you can hear a soothing
voice
andrew paul mary ryan i have been
watching your video since forever now
wow really since birth that's a young
age to start and you are definitely my
favorite reactor alongside Tyrone Magnus
you are so genuine when you talk and
funny as heck I am all the way from
Australia and I'll hope someday to meet
you might meet you somehow house
somewhere Oh as well do you reaction
videos are more YouTube channel in
trying to keep them as entertaining and
genuine as possible channel is gaby aura
HD k via caveat kev yeah yeah the
intonation can be out here mostly
british i'm mostly british right now
aren't I here like like I'm not great at
the Australian accent my goal is to
become looked uh sorry you gonna be sad
to get your ok I did did I had to my
goal is to become a successful actor as
I have a huge passion for it anyway I'll
be dub if you could shout me out and
also keep doing what you were doing that
Andrew Palmieri everyone needs to go
subscribe to caviar HD it's an awesome
channel full of awesome videos and it
features Andrew who's an aspiring actor
such as myself unlike him I'm clearly
working yeah I'm better than you Andrew
and every way possible ever forget that
don't you until like the end of your
your movie here word he really is better
than and anyway you said I'm genuine and
that was me being genuine thank you
Andrew
ah I was born to play douche bags this
is how real woman should cook you can
shut up now Jenna hey doing you always
did have a sense of humor no you little
jew you Wow yes that was the joke I told
yesterday thank you cuz I'm right I'm
right I 1a1 told her either she lost 100
bucks this can't be this can't be the
final results it is there there has to
be something you can do I don't get why
your puny woman mind cannot comprehend
the basic fact that i'm gonna keep
snoring I'm gonna keep snoring you
shouldn't talk we're recording Tyrone
you think because you're so famous you
can get away with anything
what are we gonna do Oh what I could
have done is [ __ ] caught star wars
with my buddies but now at least the 300
bucks here yours dad I need to sleep I
haven't slept this whole week I can't
take it anywhere you can sleep when I'm
out working